mon cher bernard vous avez fait beaucoup
de direct mais aussi pas mal
d'enregistrer oui est ce qu'on ne sait
pas ce que je ne savent pas c'est que
quand on enregistre parfois ça donne ça
crée du bêtisier honnêtement
ah oui mais souvent parce que c'est
compliqué surtout quand on est fatigué
ouais qu'il est deux heures du matin si
vous lui parce que j'ai et j'ai emmené
en quelque chose
bah oui je crois c'est ça que vous avez
je vous ai tendu une perche prenez là
j'ai pas dit ça vous pose des questions
comme ça gratuitement
la gamme bosser l'émission avec ce soft
sa maman a lâché prise
saveurs ça va qu'est-ce que je pense
qu'à la salle rit au début ils sont vite
arrivés là c'est pour ça que je reviens
c'était dans le bêtisier de noël oui
avec des scénarios rédiger de noël avec
futile fraioli qui m'a fait beaucoup
rire il ya beaucoup d'humour light 2
heures du matin on était vraiment
fatigué vous savez au début on regarde
bien les textes qu'on doit dire nous
sommes à la fin c'est vrai qu'on s'en
fout un peu et si on découvre au
compteur ouais bah oui mais quand même
nom mais lâchement ya pas de prompteur
parce qu'on avait changé de salle et
c'était pas possible donc on a un peu
découvert les textes et regardez ce que
ça donne voulait paris c'est du grand
n'importe quoi on découvre les textes en
plus ça se voit
[Musique]
huawei sont gbagbo mme bernard merci
justin ont bien plus à son carrosse
comme gêne et votre guerre longue
on a là les longues on me le dit souvent
huawei sont bêtes vos boules bernard
merci justin et puis en plus elles sont
bien rouge comme j'aime et votre
virement on avait tellement longue
ah ben ça va être très dur ça on vous
l'a dit souvent c'est énorme et
et vous dire langues elle est tellement
longue
écoutez on me le dit souvent nous rendre
là dedans je le sais plus haute et plus
et plus ont enchaîné on ne peut plus
s'arrêter
olympus a l'oeil qui frise à l'ailé elle
est sympa comme tout justin moi ça me
fait rire même de leur vouloir réduire
encore d'ailleurs ça fait rire parce que
c'est le texte quand même dur